- Well, where are you and
what are you up to there?
- Well, I'm in Sydney,
Australia right now,
getting ready to film "Thor."
- Yes!
- The new Thor, and--
- It's so cool that you're
going to be Lady Thor,
so do you get all of Thor's
powers is my real question?
Like I'm a huge nerd for
Avengers, any kind of superhero,
like I've seen 'em all, so do
you get powers is my question?
- So she does have powers.
(Kelly gasping)
It's not exactly the same as Thor,
it's her own version of it.
- Yes!
- And she's called the Mighty Thor.
- Oh my gosh, what a
cool character to play.
So who is her personal favorite superhero,
or a favorite superpower?
- Well, you know, I have
to say Thor, I think,
as the greatest superhero, but of course,
I mean, I'm so excited that,
you know, we're gonna have
a "Black Widow" movie,
and "Captain Marvel," of course,
and all the women of "Black Panther,"
and, you know,
there's so many exciting
characters coming up.
- I know, I think it's really important
what you just said too,
because I don't know, I
feel like when we were kids,
there wasn't as much
representation for girls.
It's kind of cool, 'cause
not only my little boy
has all these like boy
heroes to look up to,
but also female ones.
So you're right in that sense.
It's very cool.
- Yeah, that's totally true.
I mean, I think people
usually say how great it is
for the girls, but it's
really important for the boys,
you know, for boys to get to see women
in those kinds of characters,
and in those kinds of personalities,
and it just expands opportunity
for how we all see each other.
- Yeah, that's an amazing point of view,
yeah, perspective as well.